Chris Gore, Founder/Owner of
FilmThreat/Author/Filmmaker: Generally
falling down an endless chasm is the kind of death
that usually a villain experiences
leading cause of death amongst villains.
Film Courage: Let's talk about killing iconic
characters. When is it okay, when is it a horrible
mistake? Chris: I think it's really important if
you want to retain the audience for a franchise
how you kill off an iconic movie character
absolutely critical and there are places in movie
history where it's been done right and there are
places where it's been done completely wrong and
it's been bungled. It's upsetting to me I mean
first of all the death of an iconic fictional
character is already upsetting just on its face
let's talk about a case in which it was done
incredibly well in Star Trek The Wrath of Khan.
You're taking Leonard Nimoy's character Spock
who he'd played you know for decades by then
and you're now killing off this character
you're killing off Spock it's handled so well
it's not a wasteful death Spock dies in an act of
self-sacrifice trying to save the crew of the
enterprise which he'd done many times before
and skirted death and now he's you know dying in
the engine room of the enterprise facing his best
friend Jim Kirk because the important thing to
remember and this is something for screenwriters
to keep in mind is that the death of the
character is not about the person doing the dying
it's about the reaction of the characters that
love the character that's that's going through
and experiencing their death and so what we got
to experience as an audience was two longtime
friends and an act of self-sacrifice Spock is
dying and he gets to say his final words to kirk
and Kirk gets to see his friend in addition to
that that scene is followed up with a funeral
with some glorious music and and I mean we
didn't know at the time that they were setting
up a sequel star trek three the search for Spock
which kind of gives it away that Spock might be
coming back but be that as it may no one's ever
dead in in fiction but the way that that death
was handled with was handled with such respect
for all the characters involved we got it was a
satisfying in the sense that we experienced the
love that James T Kirk has for his friend Spock
and then the reactions of people who loved Spock
and and how they were affected by his death
his death had meaning conversely one of the
worst deaths ever handled in movie history
was the death of Han Solo in the force awakens
you know many people were upset with the Last Jedi
and how Luke Skywalker's character was handled but
the thing that lost it for me was han
solo's death and the Force Awakens
it's not done in any sort of act of self-sacrifice
there isn't a moment where other
characters can react to han solo's death
he's simply you know dispensed with by his own son
ben solo with a lightsaber to the heart and then
falls down an endless chasm generally falling down
an endless chasm is the kind of death that usually
a villain experiences leading cause of death
amongst villains I'm sure there's an infographic
somewhere on the internet that will tell you
this because that's how the emperor died in
the original return of The Jedi Episode six that's
how villains go out falling into an endless chasm
we don't really see the bloodiness it's off screen
that's how a villain goes out and to have Han Solo
die in that way and not have a last moment with
Chewbacca his loyal friend to not have a last
moment with Princess Leia or Luke Skywalker the
audience was completely betrayed of any meaning
for that death was betrayed by not being able
to see our beloved characters who just if you're
watching all the movies in in order a few hours
ago was alive and well and saving the universe
and my goodness if there was a child and we
had just finished watching Return to The Jedi
I don't know that I’d want to skip to the next
movie to see what happens because what happened
how the character of Han Solo was treated in his
death in the Force Awakens was offensive to me
and told me that this franchise was in the wrong
hands because you can't take a character like that
and have him go out that way you know it's not
it's not a bad thing and this used to be yes it's
a Hollywood trope you know riding off into the
sunset was was a fine way to go right it worked
for Shane it worked it worked for many iconic
Hollywood films we're gonna ride off into the
sunset maybe we don't need to see the death we can
imagine other adventures with that character but
their story has been told and they can ride off
into the sunset but if you're actually going to
kill an iconic character it needs to be done with
some level of respect and every way that that
could have been handled in a much better way which
would be the to have some final words they could
have even done it in that movie he could have been
mortally wounded by ben thinking he could have
turned his son back from the dark side to
to the light and he was mortally wounded
and you can imagine a scene with Luke Skywalker
and Princess Leia over you know a dying Han Solo
and what the words that might have been said we'll
never see that now so I I'm just I'm just offended
by that and so I think that that's if you look at
those two cases of Spock and his sacrifice in star
trek ii the wrath of khan just go watch that scene
and then you compare it with the scene of Han Solo
meaningless without even a funeral and even
the when when when Rey returns and you know
there's the knowledge that Han Solo you know is
dead she she just goes to hug Rey not not like
you know Chewbacca who she's known for decades
I that I don't understand so I really question
the thinking of some of the people in charge who
are overseeing some of these beloved franchises
and how that affected not just children who
these movies are really made for children or
for older dudes like myself who
saw the classic films as a kid
and would at least like these characters
to be treated with some level of respect
george lucas famously consulted
a child psychologist when he
toyed with the idea of making Darth
Vader the father of the hero of his movie
right he he was I don't know I want to see how
this is going to affect kids was there any vetting
done by how this might affect the audience if
you're going to handle this death in that way
and in each of the sequel trilogy
movies the deaths of the characters
are are are handled with this not not using
what I would consider to be a respectful
death which is there needs to be someone
to react to that death that is meaningful
in that in that character's life and of course
spock's best friend in the universe was Jim Kirk
so when he made that sacrifice it was meaningful
and han solo's sacrifice seemed like a waste
something else that occurs to me also
related to star wars yes a recurring
topic in conversations that I will have with
you and that I have with my friends often
you know maybe it's a form of therapy
but but what was interesting was
that when was mapping out the
story for the empire strikes back
he realized that the audience would never
believe that you would kill Luke Skywalker
so you have this lightsaber duel at the end of
the empire strikes back and it's Luke Skywalker
fighting Darth Vader where's the tension
because we already know he's making a trilogy
you're not gonna kill off Luke Skywalker so
there's really no drama or tension in that scene
so what lucas did he's like okay since they the
audience is not gonna believe that I would kill
Luke Skywalker what if the real
drama the real threat is that
Luke might turn to the dark side and because he
he he doesn't listen to Yoda's advice he doesn't
complete his training he goes off as a as as not a
fully trained Jedi and faces his greatest nemesis
who he then learns at the end of the after losing
that fight that it's his father could he turn to
the dark side and and believed that the audience
might believe that he would turn to the dark side
and and therein lies the tension whereas many
of the lightsaber duels that take place in
in the sequel trilogy are are kind of meaningless
so it's important for these characters and I
would say that if you're a Disney shareholder you
probably care even more if you want a franchise to
to continue to exist and be profitable and you
want to sell more Han Solo shirts and whatnot
that that the deaths of iconic movie
characters be treated with respect and
it's an opportunity not just for the fictional
characters that love that character in that
world to say goodbye it's an opportunity
for the audience to say goodbye as well
reminds me of a film I watched recently I think
or late 90s early 2000s and it's about a Hollywood
producer and it shows a test screening and Sean
Penn is one of the the characters in the film
playing you know he is Sean Penn in the movie
and it's the famous thing of at the end he gets
killed but does his dog so they show it to this
test audience and they're horrified and it's
a horrific scene it's awful and so that is the
big dilemma in the film do we keep that scene in
and I think Robert De Niro plays the Hollywood
producer I think it's called like what the hell
happened or something like that [Correction: What
Just Happened - 2008]. it's got an all-star cast
but where I'm going with this is test screenings
and audience feedback if you feel this way and
other fans do as well why was nothing done why
was the respect given to one character dying not
so for the other I mean I mean there's there's
actually interesting documentary that I just saw
about Alan Ladd Jr. called lady it's it's actually
made by his daughter and of course Alan Ladd Jr
was instrumental in getting star wars made but he
famously gave a lot of notes to to movies like the
exorcist and whatnot like he would give very small
notes he wasn't like telling filmmakers what to do
he was more like okay we're watching this in
a screening room and like okay but there's
this element missing sometimes it's you
know it's important to take that step back
and I do believe that test audiences test
audiences can actually help improve a film
I know that you know for example you know
I mean they call them focus groups Quentin
Tarantino has a more colorful colorful term
for focus groups he calls them focus groups
but I know I said I wouldn't swear but but
but I think that I think that it's important
to you know to to keep those kinds of feelings
and there's a lot of feelings wrapped up
in in an audience's experience
with this that's why I think these
these death scenes are so so critical the
approach to it I I'm just surprised that
the legacy characters from the previous trilogy
which if you're doing a marathon or just
you know were treated so poorly that there there
wasn't as much thought given to that you know
I you know you people have invested we're talking
about the movies here but also we're also talking
about there are comic book stories about these
characters there are stories i've made up in
my mind about these characters yes when I
played with action figures when I was a kid
you know there are stories we made
up in our heads there are novels
there are radio plays there are
all sorts of stories that this that
these iconic characters have you know have
participated in and and we've experienced those
we there's a lot invested so the callousness with
which that was done is shocking to me to this day.
Question for The Viewers: Do
you agree? Were you offended
by Hans Solo's death? What is
the most disrespectful death of an
iconic character you can think of?